hallo leute hier wieder eure mal wanne
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt wie wundert euch wahrscheinlich
gerade warum ich mich in der küche bin
das könnte auch ein mega sexistischer
witz sein aber da ich dem team taktik
machen möchte muss ich ja vorher diese
schale basteln auf der wiesn teletubbie
pudding trinken und damit meine ich
diese coole schlauchschal war vor einem
baumarkt und habe auch tatsächlich so
einen schlauch gefunden und den habe ich
schon vorbereitet wie ich bin um so eine
geschenkpapier rolle gewickelt und mit
haargummis fest gemacht damit es schon
mal diese runde form bekommt ich hoffe
wirklich dass es platz
dass der jetzt so sich gegen lässt und
auch so bleibt nicht im internet
gefunden was mir weiterhelfen könnte
also habe überlegt diesen schlauch jetzt
zu füllen damit es wie bei einem
lockenstab warm eingewickelt ist und
abkühlt und dann die form behält klingt
logisch oder abend bisher denn los
geht's und bereits es aber hier noch
nicht zu ende ich verrückt von liter
flasche den boden abzuschneiden und den
als boden von überschüssen zunehmend
kinder immer wenn ihr mit harten
gegenständen arbeitet fraktur eltern
meine mama angerufen ich mache einfach
nur da wie vor gefährlich oder
schließlich auch in der tiefe
und wir haben einen worden
ich hab einfach den wohngemeinde so groß
wie der schlauch und den schneide ich
jetzt aus und dann war das später der
schlauch durch nach ganz viel schweiß
und blut und wasser habe ich geschaffen
loch zu machen aber das seien die filme
groß darum kümmern wir uns dann später
kommt der moment auf den ich absolut
nicht gewartet habe denn das wird
wahrscheinlich ein riesengroßer fällig
soll jetzt das ding mal auf der plane
passiert das erst mal da rein zu steckt
das unverletzte links den schlauch
drumherum wickeln und das leben und die
einzige lösung wie ich es im körper war
aber okay einfach mal heißkleber so an
den schlauch
so ranmacht ich versuche es jetzt einmal
ganz kurz mit heißkleber so ein bisschen
fest zu machen und dann sag ich euch
gleich wie es gelaufen ist denn die
teletubbies ich habe wie hinbekommen
nicht so wie sie sein sollte denn wenn
ich darauf trinken würde würde ich
wahrscheinlich mehrheit liebe und
plastik schlucken als pudding aber schön
wie schales wie ich schön ist aber
eigentlich finde ich jetzt machen wir
aber den kapitän und dafür muss ich
ihnen die kirche der auch schon in
meiner küche gleich im internet keine
ventile kapitän gefunden habe habe ich
mir mal wieder selber gedanken gemacht
zuerst stellte sich mir die frage warum
ist der pudding großer mist glaube das
ist natürlich musst du die erdbeeren
treffen ob sie auch gut an
und jetzt kommt das wichtigste die creme
woraus besteht dieser kohle ich kann mir
ganz ehrlich nicht vorstellen dass die
teletubbies tierische produkte zu sich
nehmen diese noch so ausgeleuchtet vegan
deswegen habe ich keine sahne oder quark
oder so geholt sondern gesüßte schlag
krähen auf pflanzen und wasser wie haben
sie ganz sicher nimmt am anfang sind
weniger zu kriegen habe ich noch vegan
streicht bis getauft der auch mandl über
4 und fällt alles glücklich wird habe
ich plane fest besorgt das wird ein
richtiges fest und hat sich zuviel plane
festgenommen festwirt haben bio life
vanille drehen die fahrer männlich
gefällt habe eine rote lebensmittelfarbe
gesorgt
was dort gefahren erst kennen wir die
erdbeeren von ihrem spiel und dann
hatten wir ihnen unterwegs gewesen war
um gegen das schnell kommt der deckel
drauf und jetzt pürieren
in der blue card mit weiteren kümmern
uns um die kriegen zwar weniger eine
rührschüssel und machen dort und
begrüßte schlagring ein
ich bin die partie war der so coole
tricks macht liebe geräusche und jetzt
schlagen
[Musik]
ich geh jetzt während des früheren dame
streif rhein wird auf jeden fall fest
und natürlich müssen wir probieren wie
schmeckt wie schmeckt als echter seitz
sahen aber ich bin da immer ganz
schweren betrieben beigeschmack
und dies einfach so frisch und warmen
braunen blätter und blüten ich nehme die
latte von ihnen wegen frischkäse und
thun in die sahne trüffel jetzt wollen
wir die user farbe und geschmack da rein
kriegen und dafür kidnapper mache durch
so ein vieh und hoffe dass dann für
viele stückchen durchgehende machen wenn
man nur ein bisschen wir wollen wir
nicht versauen
das wissen auch wie bei baxter und lagen
[Musik]
vor dem rosa ich glaube griff er hat
leute jetzt denn das natürlich wieder
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt der
teletubbie kollegen aus kiel mit
die ist so schön geworden die bequemen
könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass die vegan
ist dass er keine warnung konnte das
widerlegten jahr so nah dran creme aus
schaut mal an die perfekte viele
kapitäne creme ist aber so leicht
und fluffig und lecker nicht erschweren
werden erklärte henderson blut
angewiesen
wir probieren die schale aus ich möchte
meinen teletubbies pudding aus meiner
seele tage schüssel essen und irgendwann
geht mit weiter lasse mir das mit dieser
schlüssel war das nicht zwar so laut ich
glaube ich bei unseren gesprächen
einfach nur funktioniert natürlich hat
diese folgen wie schmeckt gefallen und
wenn ja dann gibt mir daumen nach oben
und wenn ihr keine anderen folgen
verpassen wollt abonniert main kanals
levy schmeckt playlist an machte die
partie begann die kugel dann